there was a tick tock that Sky News or  even Australia did where a journalist  like introduces the story and then just  plays the podcast  roller coaster tragedy she was trying to  retrieve a phone from beneath the track  um what makes the story even sadder is  rodent had just learned to walk again  after being involved in a horrific car  crash if you drop your cell phone ask  someone who works there to get your  phone for you it's bad luck but roller  coasters only go in two directions it's  hard to get hit by them car okay and it  ain't gonna happen a roller coaster  that's your fault every single time  all the comments were just dunking on  this woman every single one is like  thanks for turning me on to this podcast  my favorite comment was I like how she  shakes her head when Anthony says if you  get hit by a roller coaster it's your  fault as if that's not a 100 factually  correct statement